it seems like a good time for a drink
and a cold calculated speech with
sinister overtones the speech about
politics about order Brotherhood power
but speeches are for campaigning now is
the time for action hey everybody Rick
and Morty is back we have to freak out
about that twist at the end
evil Morty is back this is so crazy the
promo they released for it was the fake
out to end all fake outs really quick
Atlantis adventure nothing special going
on in this episode at all cut to now is
the time for action so let's talk about
the mythology like the actual running
storyline because I think there's a big
hat tip for the finale because Rick's
going to be fighting the president
quote-unquote and then we'll do a stir
eggs they had so many big crowd shots
any time they do that you always try to
spot the Rick's in the background
there's always a couple Easter eggs
pepper through every single scene but if
you're new to the channel I do Rick and
Morty episodes every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's
giveaway stuff that I'll explain at the
end of the video they always make new
merch based on all the episodes you
could just guess that that Morty symbol
the pinned that they're all wearing now
is probably going to be in stores
tonight well let's crank the Eagles this
is so awesome so the beginning of the
episode opens just like the teaser they
go to Atlantis then jump back at the end
like that's all you see of it apparently
c-137 Morty just got laid I think this
is the first time he's been laid by
something that's actually alive not
including the sexbot from raising
gazorpazorp back during season one
technically that would be the first time
that he's actually had sex I don't even
want to think about the mechanics of
having sex with the mermaid maybe her
top half was a fish you guys can think
about that in the comments but then we
meet the Rick and Morty that are trying
to raise funds to rebuild the Citadel
and we find out about the real plot so
the title tales from The Citadel was
what was first reported then they
changed it on the wiki and it just read
the Rick Lantis mix-up I think the whole
reason why they tried so hard to deceive
people was just because the Citadel was
destroyed during the first episode so
they didn't want to tip their hat to the
fact that it was coming back either way
I was totally fine with it like it's
okay if you're going to deceive people when
the episode is as good as it was this is
probably one of my favorite episodes so
just in the way they were able to weave
in so many different types of stories so
many different tropes and stuff that's
happening in the real world so obviously
you detected all the elections stuff
that they were parroting in it but it
was also a collection of tropes from
urban thrillers they had a lot of
training day that was even Stand By Me
so if you're not sure what evil Morty's
plan is effectively he's just taking
over the Citadel and he's subjugating
everyone like at the beginning of the
episode when Rick refused to contribute
to the Citadel fund he said those people
are all slaves they're all prisoners of
the culture of the Citadel like he was
basically saying they're all lemmings
they're sheep to the slaughter in that
transition to the Eagle song in the city
was a nice way to highlight that like
you just see them all moving like a
bunch of sheep down the street there are
a couple Easter eggs like there's a more
tea on top of Rick's shoulders here
there's all the people in the simple
Rick Factory so you follow a couple
different threads you also probably
recognize the voice of Sam Elliott from
Lebowski
he was the stranger in that movie but he
did the voiceover for the simple Rick
commercials but evil Morty tries to use
all these divisions in the Citadel their
culture the economic the social problems
they're having to try and promise people
a better way of life so even though he
seemed like a parody of Trump they had
all the different Rick's the comb-over
Rick private sector Rick I think is the
actual parody of Trump and he really
didn't say a lot so I felt like they
actually did a good job of parroting the
u.s. election they didn't get too
heavy-handed with it but juggling Rick
was just sort of comedy Rick Rick guilt
rick is basically like the racist white
guilt Rick the rent is too damn high who
remembers that guy it's been so long
since he's been in the news then reverse
Rick outrage is like reverse racism Rick
so a whole lot of tropes with a whole
lot of us real-life politics sprinkled
in here but one of you did ask me about
the seven one six clothes so you have a
B and C and each one of them gets
progressively more disfigured I forget
who you are but you messaged me thinking
this might be Tomac sands a moth from GI
Joe but the thing is is there's no third
brother on GI Joe but I think it's just
because one has the scar the other
doesn't have the scar
I don't know necessarily that they were
going for a GI Joe thing here but we
learned that all Rick's have a uranium
implant like remember we saw the robot
Rick back during the Jerry episode
was like hey wait a minute is this
Inspector Gadget Rick what's going on
here so apparently they all have
implants like that but I guess you could
think of the simple Rick Factory is sort
of a send-up on Soylent Green mixed with
Willy Wonka like he was definitely
dressed like Willy Wonka but they're
basically eating the goo that's secreted
from simple Rick when he's really happy
and you actually see a couple Easter
eggs in this like a lot of people think
the Beth is wearing her mother's
necklace in this and we might actually
see more of her real childhood during
the ABCs of Beth episode which is in a
couple weeks they did a great job with
the cop storyline my takeaway was that
they were going for training day where
you have this really idealistic Rick
that doesn't act like other Rick's like
he's not like all the other
Rick's are supposed to be then there's
the Morty cop who hates other Morty's so
it's like Morty on Morty racism so you
probably picked up on all the social
racial undertones that they weaved into
this I mean it was done in a funny way
because it's Rick and Morty and they're
all cartoons and they're acting really
silly but I love that Morty's who are
the underclass are literally the
underclass of the Citadel so the place
where they live is called Morty town
it's a giant slum they go to the crack
house or the meth house however you want
to think about it where they have this
crazy addict Rick cooking them portal
fluid my initial takeaway is that they
were going for meth here but you could
call it crack whatever cheap drug you
want to think of but we learned what
happens when you mess up the chemistry
of portal fluid it just immediately
vaporizes him and then the whole joke
about the crib is just another send up
on urban movies like that like whenever
cops go into some sort of cracked and
there's always some crying baby in the
corner so it's just a reference to that
the Morty School is also really
interesting too like they say their
curriculum has changed we can theorize
what the new curriculum is going to be
under evil Morty's regime he'll probably
just be trying to militarize the Morty's
a little bit more but you have Severus
Snape Rick in all the Stand By Me
characters this scene is also from the
intro so it sort of breaks the false
true false true back and forth narrative
that they did last season with the intro
like scenes that are fake and scenes
that actually end up showing up during
the season so with the exception of the
but morty we might actually wind up
seeing every single part of the intro
during an episode this year a lot of you
thought that they were going for doofus
rick here tall morty
isn't the same it's just another really
dumb version of Rick so on their way to
see this great wishing portal they
actually travel to the mega trees planet
from the pilot where all the giant seeds
were we see a little dog robot that
looked kind of like canine from Doctor
Who River Phoenix Morty kind of commits
suicide we find out that is actually
just a giant trash dump so maybe he's
still alive in a giant trash pile on the
other side of that cannot wait to see
all the creepy Morty t-shirts walking
around comic-con next year is
effectively a strip club which it makes
it even more creepy because you're like
wait a minute these are all Morty's one
which is already kind of weird but -
they're all children so it's just even
nastier but really like the big ending
of the episode when evil Morty wins the
election takes power walks into the
council chamber and you learned that
they have this sort of OPEC cabal that's
been controlling the council since
before Rick blew up the Citadel in the
first episode and the original council
died so I think the only thing that they
were trying to parody here is just the
idea that there's this evil group of
businessmen that controlled the
government where evil Morty comes in and
he's supposed to be this man of the
people like he hates what Rick has done
to everyone and that's why he's on this
crazy mission it's just that we don't
know exactly what his purpose is is he
just going to try and end all of the
Rick's everywhere or is he going to try and
do something else is he going to try and
monopolize portal travel so that he
effectively rules the multiverse I think
they did a good job of bouncing back and
forth between both sides of this like
you have the Morty's and then you have
the Rick's on the other side of this
divide and they do a really good job of
balancing how terrible people are like
you have terrible Morty's you have all
these gangs that are robbing people then
you have the morty on morty violence
Morty's ending Morty's like it always
is
Rick's ending Morty's like it always is
so evil Morty who's a terrible person
himself is trying to take down Rick's
who are evil but a lot of them are just
nice working stiffs not all the Rick's
want to be bad to all the Morty's
but then you have J 20 - Rick that
gets ending by the Willy Wonka Rick and
turned into the new simple Rick so on the
serious side they actually did a really
good job of showing you that in real
world politics you have a lot of
terrible people on both sides but there
was also the silly stuff that was going
on in the episode and then you have the
serialized element of evil Morty in Rick
potentially trying to take him down in
the finale so we'll do a separate video
about it later this week but the title
of the finale is the Rick turian Morty
date as in The Manchurian Candidate the
description reads Rick has a
confrontation with the president but
people are like which President is he
talking about now we know that it's
probably going to be the president of
the Citadel who is evil Morty but I love
the way that they ended the episode
using the same song from the last evil
Morty episode so if you didn't know
already like they just built and built
it until they flipped that image over
and you actually saw the eye patch
coming off well let me know in the
comments if you guys spotted any other
Easter eggs in the episode that I didn't
mention in the video let me know what
you thought of this compared to the
other season three episodes is this new
favorite I know some people didn't like
it as much but for the most part after
the episode all my timeline was was all
caps screaming about evil Morty so
everybody seemed pretty jazzed up by it
there is a new round of that merch
giveaway that I'm doing all you have to
do to enter just be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video congratulations to
the last giveaway winner wear tape
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details what'll happen next is
this I'll post my promo video for
episode 8 tomorrow then I'll do another
evil Morty video later this week so just
leave all your evil Morty requests in
the comments below
we'll be freaking out about him for a
while click here for all my episode
Easter eggs and you can click here for
that brand new Thor trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
now is the time for action!